[Music]
here in the southeastern United States
these besieged plants have actually sent
up a chemical missed and SOS to these
black wasps why because black wasps are
known as a pod colors and some aphids
are busily sucking the life out of these
plants now despite its nickname this
wasp isn't here merely to kill the
aphids no that would be too easy like a
character in a James Bond movie
the wasp has a more exquisite punishment
for the ape with a clinical precision
the wasp injects a single egg into each
a foods body this means a slow death for
the aiviq as the wasp age grows inside
it
each wasp can plant eggs in two hundred
eight weeks
the aphids send out their own chemical
alarm systems and the colony panics but
it's too late
the wasp has done its work hasta la
vista baby and we mean baby the aphids
face a gruesome death the ravenous wasp
larvae will eat the aphid alive from the
inside out the aphids body becomes the
incubator for the young of its predator
a new generation of assassins will soon
emerge littering these killing fields
with corpses okay now here's the money
shot the young wasp emerging to seek out
more aphids to begin this cycle all over
again the wasp
with its exquisitely deathly plan and
yet just doing what nature's programmed
it to do
[Music]